In the closing years of the Sengoku Era,
Japan was consumed by perpetual conflict.
In this fight, between the large warrior and the swordsman, note the crest on the helmet of the smaller warrior.
It's almost identical to the one that the Ashina clan's Commander wears.
So this swordsman is either that same main antagonist
of "Sekiro: Shadows Die Twice" who goes on to cut off our arm or
More likely, it's the grandfather of the commander who is known as the legendary Ashina Isshin.
He was a Sword Saint who wrested this country from its former owners and who went on this big campaign to
embed the Ashina clan within this country.
If so, this battle that we're seeing here could be the battle that started at all.
In the aftermath of the fight, our young Sekiro kneels on the battlefield and he's unaware or uncaring
that he's being approached by another warrior.
What's the matter stray nothing left to lose?
Considering he already has two katanas on his back and he's being called a stray?
He may either be looting the battlefield or perhaps he's wishing that he was stronger
because it's possible that he has indeed lost everything
Well, would you look at that?
Will you join me, starving wolf?
The grizzled warrior who is covered in this sash of feathers is
almost certainly The Owl - a man who took Sekiro under his wing and raised him to become The Wolf.
We know this because in another trailer, one of The Owl's old acquaintances named Lady Butterfly
Calls us his brat and as Sekiro grabs the Owl's sword. He displays his willingness
to start anew.
He is later, we realized how the grown-up wolf got that scar
That day, I pulled you from the battlefield.
I had no idea what you'd become.
With this trailer,
you can already see the tragedy unfolding.
We get this chilling insight into why a shinobi feels so driven to recover the prince after we lose him.
It's because The Owl rescued Sekiro from the battlefield and raised him as a sort of foster father and
Sekiro - The Wolf - us
We were not able to be that same man to the foster child we lost.
In the coming 24 hours, I'm going to be releasing another video called the "Prosthetic Art Challenge"
and if you're an artist, if you know an artist or hell if you feel like commissioning an artist for this.
Please get involved or spread the word, the goal put simply is to design a prosthetic arm weapon that we haven't seen before.
For prizes, I'm putting up $1500 of my own money for the top ten entrants.
We've got Humble Bundle keys for the runners-up and there's a potential
mystery prize if you send in your submission within two weeks.
The goal is to give pretty much every serious entrant a prize and
because I'm going to be showing off the winners and their portfolio in another video.
Hey, this could be a cool opportunity if you're an artist looking to make a name for yourself
And I know everyone in the comments will appreciate the hell out of any art you make for us.
So check out the video in the description!
For more details on how to enter,
I'll be giving you guys an art template that you can draw on and a lot more details.
So check it out and I hope to see you there!!